HE HAS CERTAINLY BEEN HOT
LATELY. OST IT TO SCHEIFELE.
BLOCKER SAVE, REBOUND!
WHEELER TAKES IT AWAY FROM  FORK
YOU CAN GET THEM.
LOOK AT THE EVACUATION OF THE
TIGHT SPACE AND COLIN WHITE
CHUMS THIS ONE. . NE AND BREAKS
POINT.
DECISION.
THIS IS AN ANXIOUS TIME OF YEAR
SOMETIMES ALLOWING YOUR GROUP TO
GO ON THE
BY HELLEBUYCK.
WELL AFTER THE WHISTLE GOES.
>> THERE'S OFF BY SVECHNIKOV.
DEFLECTED IN FRONT. IT.
>> THE
AND IT'S ON FOR APPLETON.
APPLETETMANY NIGHTS.
FIVE HITS IN THAT GAME THREE WA
HIM SLIDE AROUND THE
BRANNSTROM.
SCHEIFELE.
CAME OFF A
OF HIM BUT A BREAK DOWDEMELO,
ESE LAST FIVE OR SO MINUTES,
A HUGE WIN FOR THE STARS.
JUMP UP TO 75 POINTS. D.
AND ANOTHER STOP.
THAT WAS A DANAN GET CHIPPED AH
FOR MATTHEW JOSEPH WITH ENNIS TS
AT THE END ON FOR NORRIS.
BACK FOR BRANNSTROM.
EEDED TO BE INSIDE.
THERE'S THAT LANE TO IN FRONT,
TO GET SPEED
BROWN SENDS IT AROUND THE 40 ON
SCHMIDT BACK INTO HIS OWN  GOALO
ASSISTS ON THE GOAL FOR
SCHEIFELE.
THIS GETS SENATORS WERE ABLE TOY